[Musica]
oggi voglio raccontarvi una storia
la storia di una ragazza piena di dubbi
su se stessa sulla strada da prendere
che un bel giorno ha aperto un cassetto
dell'archivio di suo nonno e ha
incominciato a conoscere se stessa
attraverso l'approfondimento delle sue
radici
il nonno di questa ragazza si chiamava
Franco Albini ed era considerato un
maestro della progettazione
architettonica del design delle
innovazioni museali
niente di più lontano dal mondo di lei
che invece era un innamorata del Teatro
delle pratiche spirituali e della vita
in genere insomma una di quelle che
sperimentano un po' tutto ma non
approfondiscono veramente niente
Lui
razionalista Lei emotivista
lui silenzioso lei ciarliera lui maestro
e lei indisciplinata discepola poi chi
fosse veramente Franco Albini lei non lo
sapeva si sapeva che era un architetto
un designer un urbanista ma poco di più
ma è stato solo parecchi anni dopo la
sua morte
approfondendo la sua opera che questa
ragazza ha incominciato a capire che
cosa significasse essere un innovatore
cioè un uomo che riusciva a scomporre e
a ricomporre la realtà
proiettandosi nel futuro e anticipando
risposte ha bisogno che ancora dovevano
emergere
insomma questa ragazza era profondamente
affascinata dall'idea di capire quali
fossero gli ingredienti che avevano
portato suo nonno a essere un innovatore
e Franco Albini era un innovatore era un
uomo che
considerava la propria professione come
una missione sociale
pensate che già negli anni trenta quando
ancora non esisteva nemmeno l'idea del
design industriale Alpini già scomponeva
i mobili pensava mobili che potessero
essere scomponibili facilmente
trasportabili e facilmente
riassemblabili portando per primo la
vite a brugola all'interno del mobile di
design e anticipando Ikea di più o meno
una trentina d'anni lui diceva che è più
dalle nostre opere che diffondiamo delle
idee che non attraverso noi stessi
Infatti dentro alle sue opere Albini
aveva nascosto dei messaggi nella
bottiglia che erano arrivati fino a lei
e l'aveva insegnato nel tempo la dignità
e rispetto per se stessi
l'orgoglio della modestia e soprattutto
la coerenza
in tutta la sua carriera Albini ha
realizzato più di 22.000 di segni
nell'ambito dell'architettura del design
dell'urbanistica Ma nonostante i diversi
ambiti di intervento Nella sua opera si
può sempre riconoscere una stessa cifra
stilistica uno stesso procedimento
un'identità ben precisa Ma com'è
possibile che il disegno di una
seggiolina possa avere lo stesso
procedimento del disegno di una grande
architettura Che cosa lega progetti così
diversi tra loro bene in caso di Albini
verrebbe da rispondere la leggerezza il
rigore la razionalità poetica ma questi
sono solo effetti formali superficiali
che nascondono però un metodo ben
preciso oggi battezzato il metodo Albini
che questa ragazza ha incominciato a
leggere come un processo non solo per
una buona progettazione architettonica
ma anche per la progettazione di una
buona vita e i cui primi tre principi
corrispondono in maniera sorprendente al
tema di questo Ted perché sono scomporre
cercare l'essenza e ricomporre in forma
nuova
principi che Albini ha adottato in tutta
la sua opera scomponendo le architetture
e gli oggetti legati alla tradizione
togliendo ogni orpello quindi cercando
l'essenza E ricomponendo questa essenza
in forma nuova come nel caso della sua
radio in cristallo del 1938 una vecchia
radio in legno Avete presente Le radio
di quell'epoca che Albini scompone cioè
rompe la scatola per guardarci dentro e
per ricomporre le componenti elettriche
ovvero l'essenza ciò che fa funzionare
una radio in forma nuova
e dando vita poi a un oggetto mobile
radio lui mette questi
ingranaggi elettrici all'interno di
lastre di cristallo dando vita ad un
mobile radio che ha anticipato il
concetto dell'itech di più o meno una
cinquantina d'anni
nascondendo all'interno della
trasparenza delle sue lastre un
messaggio che questa ragazza ha
incominciato a leggere come un messaggio
fondamentale ma non solo per se stessa
ma anche per gli altri liberarci
spogliarci dalle sovrastrutture e
cercare di catturare l'essenza di quello
che siamo e di quello che facciamo
insomma questi Principi a questa ragazza
sono sembrati come un modello
rivoluzionario nella sua semplicità
attualissimo anche per ogni percorso di
crescita perché sono passi
consequenziali per
trasformare scomporre e ricomporre
scomporre e ricomporre non è solo un
procedimento per la buona architettura
ma anche per la buona vita perché per
elevarci ognuno di noi ha bisogno di
scomporre le vecchie credenze i vecchi
condizionamenti bisogna riconoscerli per
poterli lasciare andare
e una volta fatto questo si crea lo
spazio per poter ricostruire anche la
nostra vita in forma nuova più libera
più creativa
Vi è mai capitato di trovarvi
imprigionati tra in vecchi schemi di
pensiero e di comportamento che vi
riportano sempre al punto di partenza
è lì che dobbiamo rompere la scatola
come ha fatto Albini con la sua radio
che dobbiamo vedere
guardare per scomporre
trasformare e ricomporre in forma nuova
Questo è quello che è successo a me
quando ho aperto quel cassetto molto
tempo fa
Io
ero quella ragazza che a un certo punto
è diventata donna attraverso la
conoscenza di un'eredità di un'eredità
spirituale l'eredità di un maestro che
era anche suo nonno e questo percorso mi
ha davvero trasformato Cioè a un certo
punto dopo avere
scomposto è ricomposto la mia vita dopo
una laurea in scienze dell'educazione
dopo avere lavorato in teatro per molti
anni
ho conosciuto sono rimasta folgorata da
questo architetto che non ho mai
conosciuto in vita Ma che davvero mi ha
trasformato e mi ha dato il coraggio e
ha detto il coraggio di uscire dagli
schemi e di portare un po' della mio
mondo dentro al suo
così dopo aver fatto il mio percorso
sono potuta ritornare alle mie radici ho
avuto bisogno di tornare indietro per
andare avanti di capire da dove venivo
e in questo modo ho avuto il coraggio di
aprire una fondazione di seguire
l'intuizione di aprire una fondazione
ormai molti anni fa e di appena l'ho
aperta quando appena dopo aver aperto
quel cassetto dell'archivio ho scritto
uno spettacolo che ho lasciato in un
cassetto poi per otto anni per paura
perché non lo ritenevo adeguato al
contesto ma è stato solo quando ha avuto
il coraggio di aprire quel cassetto e di
mettere in scena quello spettacolo che
tra l'altro Ironia della sorte quello
spettacolo si chiamava proprio il
coraggio del proprio tempo che è
scattato un click e si sono aperte le
strade che hanno dato significato alla
mia vita al mio tempo e al mio lavoro
a un certo punto ho smesso di aspettare
e di credere che ci fosse bisogno di
soldi per realizzare le cose e ho
incominciato a realizzare le cose che
hanno attratto le risorse necessarie
a un certo punto ho capito che il
coraggio Come diceva Goethe ha veramente
in sé genio potere e magia e che quando
si crede in se stessi e nelle cose che
si fanno questo è la più grande
generatore di fiducia e di opportunità
e quindi ho aperto una fondazione e col
tempo ho capito anche quanto il metodo
di mio nonno che era fondato su su
questi principi scomporre cercare
l'essenza e ricomporre ma anche
verificare e agire con responsabilità
sociale
verificare significa Franco era
letteralmente ossessionato dalla
verifica tanto che era capace di stare
sul disegno di una seggiolina per più di
15 anni
ma verificare Non significa solo
monitorare il percorso ma significa
anche fidarci di una prima idea di una
prima intuizione e andarci a fondo
sempre più a fondo per vedere dove ci
porta e nella sua opera Albini ci
insegna anche che quando un'idea È buona
quando è davvero funzionale non va
abbandonata Ma va monitorata va
esplorata va approfondita nel tempo
migliorandola sempre curandola nei
dettagli
e dandole anche il tempo di manifestare
tutte le sue potenzialità e poi c'è il
quinto principio del metodo Albini che è
la responsabilità sociale che è il
motore dovrebbe quantomeno essere il
motore di ogni azione è il principio
cardine che può trasformare ciò che
ognuno di noi fa e anche il lavoro di
ognuno di noi in un contributo verso il
prossimo e che in alcuni casi può
rendere anche il dopo di noi la parte
più lunga della nostra vita come diceva
Gio Ponti
certi uomini sono pluri millenari e
forse Albini è stato uno di questi o
quantomeno lo è stato per quella ragazza
che poi oggi è diventata donna e per
molti altri che hanno approfondito la
sua opera
perché Albini nascondeva nelle sue opere
dei messaggi nella bottiglia che sono
arrivati fino a noi e la mia esperienza
è un'esperienza di trasformazione di
scomposizione e di ricomposizione di una
ragazza piena di dubbi che oggi sa che
quello che vuole fare è contaminare è
tradurre la cultura del passato in nuovi
linguaggi che possano portare sostegno
agli altri
Albini è un uomo che non è più solo un
nonno non è più solo un maestro del
razionalismo italiano ma è un uomo che
ci ha lasciato un metodo una un'eredità
spirituale una segnaletica di
orientamento che può davvero aiutare a
trasformare e tanto che
anni fa quando ha aperto quel cassetto
ho aperto la fondazione ho scritto
quello spettacolo ho avuto il coraggio
di mettere questo spettacolo in scena e
questa cosa ha fatto accadere tante cose
e dopo tanti anni ho fondato anche una
Academy per portare questo metodo come
insieme a professionisti in ambiti
interdisciplinari a sostegno della vita
degli altri E questa cosa si è rivelata
straordinaria e in questi anni Abbiamo
lavorato lì dove sentivamo che ce n'era
più bisogno abbiamo portato abbiamo
lavorato con i giovani adolescenti che
prima ancora di acquisire nozioni
avrebbero bisogno di conoscere il loro
valore abbiamo lavorato con
gli studenti universitari
per sensibilizzarli al loro ruolo
professionale alla responsabilità che
c'è dentro il loro ruolo professionale
nel portare
soluzione a bisogni che ancora dovevano
emergere abbiamo lavorato con aziende
per lavorare sulle relazioni sulla
leadership gentile ma anche abbiamo
portato questo metodo a tutte le persone
in genere tanto smarrite in questo mare
di complessità Per portarle ad
abbracciare la loro fragilità per
tornare a confrontarsi e per affrontare
le sfide con creatività anche sfide come
il cancro durante il covip infatti
abbiamo lavorato con un gruppo di
pazienti o oncologiche portando il
metodo per portarla a raccontare la loro
storia di trasformazione attraverso
l'esperienza della malattia e da questo
percorso è nato uno spettacolo che si
chiama il talento della malattia che è
nato per raccontare sensibilizzare su
quello che accade in termini emotivi
relazionali e psicologici in chi sta
vivendo l'esperienza della malattia e
anche al senso profondo che questa
esperienza porta con sé in termini di
cambiamento e di rinascita
vedete Quante realtà possono nascere
dalla cultura del passato quando la si
percepisce in continuità con la nostra
vita di oggi
perché la cultura non è una cosa
astratta è una cosa viva e come la
traccia di chi è venuto prima di noi che
ci passa il testimone Affinché anche noi
possiamo fare la nostra parte ma insieme
al testimone i maestri ci danno anche
degli strumenti per rendere la nostra
vita meno faticosa
contaminare
usare connettere le storie le persone
questo è quello che io voglio fare nella
vita e
questo è quello che questo metodo mi ha
insegnato che è possibile fare perché
mio nonno aveva ragione è più dalle
nostre opere che diffondiamo delle idee
che non attraversano gli stessi le
nostre opere sono lo specchio di noi
stessi sono quello che di noi rimarrà
sono la nostra eredità per il mondo
perché attraverso i nostri pensieri le
nostre parole e le nostre azioni noi
tracciamo un'eredità che un giorno
qualcun altro raccoglierà
E allora la domanda con cui voglio
lasciarvi oggi è
quali messaggi vogliamo lasciare noi
come Albini ha fatto dentro le sue opere
che messaggi vogliamo lasciare noi
attraverso le nostre opere e attraverso
quello che siamo e quello che facciamo
Grazie